yesterday around 5:30 p.m. Eastern u.s.
time we learned about an explosion just
outside the Manchester Arena in
Manchester England where an ariana
grande concert was wrapping up around
10:30 at night there time local time we
now know that this was the deadliest
terrorist attack in Britain since 2005
the death toll is at 22 as of just a few
minutes ago with 59 people hospitalized
some with life-threatening injuries as
soon as it was made clear that this was
a suicide bombing not some kind of
mishap a gas explosion or something like
that it immediately was clear that this
was the mo of radical Sunni Muslim
radicals and this is important this is
the reality when you ask who is
currently doing suicide bombings in this
fashion in public places it is the style
of radical Sunnis this includes Isis it
includes Saudi extremists and indeed the
perpetrator Salman Abedi known to
British authorities a 23 year old man is
the believed attacker that has been
identified by British police known as a
radical Muslim in the United Kingdom a
second 23 year old man has been detained
for possible connections to the incident
we don't know too much about that yet
Isis has taken responsibility for the
attack does not necessarily mean
anything in particular operationally
until we found out find out more about
the degree of what that responsibility
is or maybe we've just got to be honest
here Pat and you know I I do not believe
that there is anything fundamentally
wrong with saying I am NOT surprised by
what we've learned about the perpetrator
here the pattern was not indicative of a
young British member of the local
skeptic society no one thought upon
hearing the mo of this attack that it
sounds like something a Jewish woman
would do a Jew a British Jewish woman
immediately it was the signature of a
Sunni Muslim man radicalized in the
style of Isis or the Saudi terrorists
who carried out 9/11 and indeed it was
and further the sophistication of
the bomb which according to early
reports was packed with nails and other
would-be shrapnel would suggest some
degree of collaboration beyond just the
suicide bomber themselves and again we
don't yet know how far that
collaboration or coordination goes a few
thoughts here this was an ariana grande
concert this is filled with little kids
more girls than boys preteens teenagers
imagine we are talking about an attempt
here to target a place where we know
young people are going to be imagine
your daughter going to a concert with
her friends or my little sister who's 13
going to this concert and then this
happening as they're leaving a girl as
young as 8 years old was killed here and
terror works the likelihood at being
killed at a music concert remains almost
zero consider the number of concerts
that there were yesterday consider the
number in the last year but now because
of this one incident this is on our
minds you know parents will say no you
can't go to that show even though the
risk of this happening is still
infinitesimally low this is exactly what
it's designed to do and Miley Cyrus is
now saying she's going to cancel parts
of her tour that's not good news yeah I
mean unfortunately Isis has a history of
going after women and children in this
case there was a victim as young as
eight years old and that's actually a
more new phenomenon I mean a other
political terrorist organizations don't
deliberately go after women and children
because they just don't think it's going
to reflect well towards their cause and
and so that's another reason why there
are some and you know every every
so-called terrorism expert national
security expert comes out of the
woodwork every time this happens and
there there's this feeling that some
kind of red line has been crossed
because ariana grande concert
eight-year-old girl who was killed
there's another aspect to this which is
less subjective and more objective which
is this happened outside of security
this is equivalent to in an airport
before you've passed TSA screening where
we have seen some terrorist acts done
imagine at many of our sports stadiums
including even here in Boston how do you
secure some of these areas because you
have a
at Fenway Park where the Red Sox play
you now have had the security perimeter
in some parts moved outside of the
stadium so just to get on to I believe
it's yaki way you have to go through
security before even getting onto that
Street but just outside of that is still
just as crowded of an area and there's
it
I've been saying it for over a year now
we expected Isis to lose territory in
the Middle East but how do you stop or
rather prevent these types of incidents
that's where the conversation inevitably
goes to the issue here is that not only
do you have arenas but often times they
are subway stations and train stations
right directly beneath them and that's
what was the case in this Manchester
arena also the same thing with Penn
Station right below Madison as our
garden yeah so you know you can have
checkpoints and different security
apparatuses but if you're dealing with
the train station you can't really
impede people's ability to move it's
incredibly difficult we have that here
in Boston now that you mentioned it I
mean the TD Garden where the Boston
Celtics in Boston Bruins play is above
North Station which is a prominent train
commuter rail I don't know if Amtrak
goes out of there I think Amtrak is
mostly out of South Station but there
may be some going out of there so this
is a sort of operational reality and
again the mere fact that we are now
talking about this that is the point of
these incidents that is the entire point
of carrying out something like this now
parents are saying you can't go to the
concert people are saying hey what's the
difference between an event that's a
music show and an event that is a
sporting event what about the fact that
there are mass transit stations and
anybody can get onto a train or subway
with effectively no security process
whatsoever in most of the United States
and and most of Europe as well this is
exactly the point it's a horrible
horrible tragedy I'm sort of at a loss
as to what else we can really say about
it but this is clearly something that is
the growing mo of radical groups like
Isis and I I don't know what the next
step is as far as this goes